if you feel the pain point of something
the chances are somebody else feels it
as well
if you can genuinely say you are
creating something that would help you
that would solve a personal problem
personal struggle for you you're going
to find success the last decade has been
so focused on connecting people
digitally and predominantly with people
you already know yet it's never been
approached from a female perspective it
was time that somebody said let's not
just connect people that you already
know let's not just give you a platform
to stay in touch well let's give you a
platform to actually make new
connections empowered connections and
let's do it in a way that really
challenges the status quo the norms in
the sense that women can make the first
move women are equal and that's why I
set out to do that in dating and in
friendship and here we are at business
and networking Bumble biz is our new
networking vertical inside of the
pre-existing Bumble app you're not
onboarding into a dating app you are
onboarding into a new social network for
people you don't know there are three
verticals there is bumble dating there
is bumble for friends which is bumble
vff and now there's the newly launched
bumble biz for business and networking
making the first move transcends just
dating and making the first move as a
woman sets the stage saying I want to be
respected I'm confident I'm in control
I'm an equal and then it encourages the
party on the other end to respect her as
such and so with bumble biz now we're
tackling sexism in the workplace by
having women make the first move be
confident have a voice stand up for what
you believe in go after what you want
and we're really excited to see where it
goes we let our users guide our
innovation we let our users guide our
brand and it's all about listening to
this generation of women and all the
other generation of women that might be
able to use this platform and and
letting their desires
their dreams and their wishes guide
where we take this next because this is
for them anybody that is willing to
challenge the status quo is going to be
met with a lot of naysayers that is just
how it goes people don't like change if
you set your mind to it if you stay
extremely loyal to your values to your
team to being a good person in your day
to day life and you work harder than you
ever thought you would ever have to work
there will be light at the end of the
tunnel days can be long bad days can be
even longer and it's very important to
stay true to what you're doing and
realize that anything worth fighting for
is not going to come easy
[Music]
you